so it looks like chris hemsworth has
finally met his match Jack Black tackled
Chris's hard court dumbbell workout
asking who did it better and Thor gave
it up to the god of rock responding
quote this student has now become the
master that's such a hard move - but
check yourself guys imagine doing that
workout in
some heels that is how miss Mariah Carey
wrote she's launching her new tour
tonight in Dallas looking fabulous
darling so we're breaking down Mariah's
Beauty playbook I do work out and I do
water aerobics but oh you're doing a bad
angle of my legs yeah Mariah could give
us a masterclass in camera angles you're
a little closer on me aren't you I wish
made a fair and the perfect lighting I
will not be seen without sunglasses but
the 48 year old also follows a more
basic Beauty role to keep aging at bay
wear sunscreen darling her other
strategy to staying young pretend age
doesn't exist I don't have birthdays in
Mariah's world you celebrate
anniversaries instead I love it
the Divas been known to dabble in some
interesting beauty treatments like
bathing a cold melt to keep her skin
hydrated and she got a massage from a
backbiting masseuse you heard that right
but opted out of the biting part she
freaked out that was probably the most
challenging massage I've ever had in my
life
right okay clam we're doing glam Mimi's
motto when it comes to makeup less is
more
why well she's not a fan of taking it
all off I don't even really wear my hate
mascara the Divas not shy about her
disdain for diets either during one swim
down all she ate was salmon and capers
but when it comes to workouts mariah has
no problem being extra yep she's wearing
fishnets and heels on a Stairmaster I
mean I always go on the Stairmaster in
my heels you know cat what yeah I've
seen you won't do it all it's so grand
keeping Mariah of course is for 35 year
old boyfriend Bryan Tanaka yep she's
still dating her former backup dancer
they've been on off for more than two
years
[Music]